Here is a visualization of the RGB color space. The axis to the left shows the
red channel increasing. The vertical axis is green. And the channel to the right
is blue. We can't see the interior of the cube showing intermediate values. All
the values we can see in this particular have one or more channels at the
maximum. Here's a view inside the cube with the red and blue axes swapped. Next,
this direction doesn't really matter. The point inside the cube shows how sky
blue is formed by the RGB values of 1 5th red, 3 5th green, and 4 5th blue.
Another way to visualize the RGB color space, is to take a slice of the cube at
these three corners. Each corner represents a single color channel at full
intensity, with the other two channels off. For example this vertex is where
green is set to one and red and blue are 0. By slicing a plane through these
three corners, we'll be able to see where red plus green plus blue equal 1. This
slice gives another view of how these colors blend. This is what the next
exercise is about.